this is the iPhone se does it look
familiar because it should it's
basically the insides of the iPhone 6s
which is the latest best iPhone with the
outsides of the 5s
there are a couple of little changes
there's a stainless steel logo on the
back there's an SE here and on the edges
it's a little more matte rather than
quite so shiny and glossy but otherwise
it's the same design and people love
this design so that's a good thing the
upside though is it's not an old phone
anymore it's very much new it has the a9
processor and the m9 coprocessor it has
live photos and the new camera and
everything it's $399 which is the
cheapest iPhone Apple has ever sold
it's $499 if you get 64 gigs or 399 for
16 it's a thoroughly modern good phone
for people who just wants smaller phones
and it turns out there are a lot of
those people it's just the iPhone only
smaller